(percussive music)
- [Arthur] As a drummer,
I've always been fascinated
by the power of rhythm.
It's the heartbeat of music,
the driving force that moves us.
I've spent my life exploring percussion
and pushing the boundaries
of what's possible with sticks and skins.
But there's another kind of beat
that's been around for centuries.
One that's not played on drum
but on a different kind of
instrument, the human body.
♪ Here we go now ♪
(beatboxing music)
- [Linda] This is beatboxing,
the art of creating rhythm and sound
using only the human voice.
(beatboxing music)
- [Arthur] As a drummer, I'm
fascinated by this art form
and how it compares to what I do.
Can the human body really compare
to the power of a drum kit?
(drum beats)
- [Linda] Arthur and I are going to meet
with beat boxers from across the country
to better understand the history
of beatboxing and its
impact on music today.
(beatboxing music)
(both laughing)
- Alright, let's not do
that, let's not do that.
- [Arthur] So I'm meeting up
with Karnish, the executioner today.
A beatboxing legend here in Minneapolis.
Oh, he's been all over the world though,
he's been touring the world.
I got my drums with me today,
we're gonna get in here and create.
I'm very excited to work with Karnish.
I've played with him a few times before
at jam sessions here and there,
but today is gonna be special.
Oh here he is, what am I?
- Good to see you, man.
- Likewise.
- I've been too long bro.
(beatbox music)
What are some common
misconceptions about beatboxing
that you run into?
- One is that it's not music,
a lot of them say it's making
noises with your mouth.
A lot of people don't lead
first foot forward saying music.
(beatbox music)
I disagree, I think that
noises are musical too.
You know, every instrument makes a noise
and it's turned into music.
- Music.
(beatbox music)
- Another misconception is that,
not everybody can learn how to beatbox.
(beatbox music)
But anybody can learn
how to turn themselves
into an instrument.
And that's what I believe beatboxing is.
It's the art of transforming
your body into an instrument.
(beatbox music)
- The art of creating music
with your mouth, throat and
body goes back to ancient times.
But the culture of
beatboxing as we know it
didn't emerge until the 1970s and 80s.
Back then, the word beatbox
was used to describe drum machines,
like the CR-7030 or the legendary TR-808.
So when early pioneers
started mimicking drum sounds
with their mouths, that became
known as human beatboxing.
(train engine roaring)
Right now we are in New York City,
the birthplace of beatboxing.
But we're gonna travel
across the Hudson River
to Jersey City to visit the Beatbox House.
A collective of beat boxers
who have won multiple
world battle championships.
The band originated in
Brooklyn over a decade ago
and is made up of five core members.
Gene Shinozaki,
(Jean beatboxing)
Kenny Urban,
(Kenny beatboxing)
Napom,
Amit,
(Kenny beatboxing)
and Chris Celiz.
The boundary pushing group
says they aim to rebrand the art form.
The notion that I have is
that you started the group.
- Yes.
- Is that correct?
Okay, so how did you start the group?
- Basically we wanted a place where people
could come who would beatbox,
you know, to beatbox.
(beatbox music)
- You know, we would see each
other at every competition,
you know, we would consistently
be in like the top five.
So we were like, let's form a group.
- Yeah.
- You know,
you start doing this thing
that's really weird just by yourself,
but you know you really enjoy
it and you just keep doing it,
and you want to find
other people like that.
♪ What it is to live ♪
- [Linda] Though, the
members of Beatbox House
made their name by winning
world battle titles,
they told me that their focus has changed
to making original music
and exporting American beatbox culture
to other parts of the world.
- What we're doing now is
producing music basically, right?
We're making these electronic tracks,
but instead of Gene picking a synth to use
and pitching it we're just using,
(Napom beatboxing)
and then boom.
(beatbox music)
- [Linda] What are some misconceptions
that people have about beatboxing?
- That it's a party trick,
that's like the biggest thing,
people are like, oh,
that's a cool party trick,
you do a sound and they're like,
oh that's a cool party trick.
But what we're doing is
trying to show people
that beatboxing is music.
(both beatboxing)
- [Arthur] Today, beatboxing
is an international phenomenon
with a global battle scene that pulls
in millions of viewers online.
And beatboxing can be found
in the recordings of hip hop songs.
(upbeat music)
It's even made its way into
songs outside of hip hop
like this one from Thorm Yorke.
(upbeat music)
So how did the art of beatboxing grow
to become so influential?
- It all started during
the early days of hip hop.
Back then beatboxing became an
alternative to drum machines
which were not very affordable.
Early beat boxers learned
to mimic the sounds of drums
when a drum machine wasn't available.
Beat boxers accompanied MCs
on the streets during ciphers,
on stage at a show, and
even in recorded songs.
♪ La di da di, we like the party ♪
♪ We don't cause trouble ♪
♪ We don't bother nobody where ♪
- [Arthur] But beatboxing
didn't stay the accompaniment,
eventually it became the main attraction.
Pioneers like Doug E. Fresh,
Buffy from the Fat Boys,
and Bis Markie will take
beatboxing to new heights
by incorporating beatboxing
both on stage and in the studio.
The track "La Di Da Di" by
Doug E. Fresh and Slick Rick
became an instant classic
from one of the most sampled
tracks in hip hop history.
(beatbox music)
- How is beatboxing important
to the history and culture of hip hop?
- It's the instrument that
you always have on you.
It's the easiest way to be
a part of hip hop culture.
(Napom beatboxing)
- A lot of people now say,
beatboxing isn't just hiphop
it's idiom, it's dance
music, blah, blah blah,
but I still feel like
beatboxing is still hip hop.
Because for me, hip hop
isn't just a style of music,
it's a culture, and beatboxing kind of,
it's stemmed from that
culture of like, you know,
people being oppressed
and trying to speak out
express themselves and beatboxing
is a form of expression, you know.
- As the art form of beatboxing grew,
more artists began contributing
by innovating and creating new techniques.
Artists like Kenny Muhammad,
Rahzel, Wise, D-Cross,
Kid Lucky and many, many more.
Kid Lucky specifically was an
important mentor and teacher
for other rising beatboxers in the scene.
By the nineties,
beatboxing was well known.
Even Queen Latifah got
her start beatboxing
for the group Ladies Fresh.
- As beatboxing grew in popularity
in underground battle
scene began to emerge,
Kenny Muhammad and Rahzel became
stars in the battle scene,
this health beatboxing
popularity spread overseas
where competitions popped
up across the world.
I got to meet some of the
best battlers in the world.
The members of the Beatbox House
all got their start by
rising through the ranks
of the international battle scene.
- Well, the main avenue for
beatboxing is the competition,
especially with a lot of young kids,
like they want to get into this thing
and they see that that's the lane,
so it's like, okay, let me invest my time
into like learning how to do that.
'Cause that's what we did,
like our goal is like,
let's win world champs,
like let's win grand
beatbox battle, and we did.
♪ Because it's a beatbox ♪
(beatbox music)
- Beatboxing became a sensation online
where battle videos and YouTube tutorials
help bring beatboxing
to millions of new fans.
As the community continues to grow,
there are more and more
women taking over the scene
and winning titles.
like Kaila Mullady, DJ Hershe,
Pe4enkata, and many more.
(Napom beatboxing)
Napom has dozens of battle titles.
So I couldn't pass up the opportunity
to ask him for a quick beatbox lesson.
Okay, I'm so nervous to ask
but can you teach me how to do something?
- Yeah.
- Something easy,
I am a singer, but like
I am not a beatboxer.
- The basic one is boots and cats.
- Okay.
- So there's three sounds.
(Napom beatboxing)
- Okay.
- So the first one is the B,
you just gotta make a hard B sound.
So like,
(Napom beatboxing)
Do that like five times.
- It's hard.
(Linda beatboxing)
Yeah, precisely.
- Okay.
- And then,
(Napom beatboxing)
So it's like a T and S together.
So if you go,
and then add a little, after.
The last one is the K,
So C where a K sound.
So just,
(Napom beatboxing)
(Linda laughs)
- Like that.
- Pretty much perfect,
you just want to try to put
some more energy into that.
Feel that,
(both beatboxing)
(Linda laughs)
Yeah, so now you gotta put
the three sounds together
boots and cats and yeah,
keep it going, keep it going.
(both beatboxing)
(Linda laughs)
Cool.
- Nice.
- Okay.
(beatbox music)
- [Arthur] So we know how
beatboxing got it start,
but I still want to know how it stacks
up to someone playing the drums.
So to put it to the test,
I challenge Karnish to a
friendly game of horse.
- Okay, so I was thinking
the idea would be
like a kind of a game of horse,
call and response,
you do something and I'll try to replicate
what you do on here.
- Okay.
- Let's do that
for a couple minutes and
then we'll switch it around.
(Karnish beatboxing)
(drum beats music)
Okay, let's go, let's
switch it around, all right?
(drum beats music)
(Karnish beatbox)
(Karnish beatboxing)
(drum beats music)
That's cool, I like that, I like that.
That's tough.
Who do you feel like it's
harder for a beatboxer
to emulate drum sounds
or a drummer to emulate a beatboxer sound?
- You're probably thinking
it's as hard for you
as I'm thinking it is for me.
- Exactly.
- Because for me, I feel
like there's certain stuff
my mouth can't do,
and you're probably thinking
well my hands can't do
what his mouth is doing.
- My foot can't do that, that you doing?
(Karnish beatboxing)
- 'Cause that's not a double kick,
that's like a triple or whatever it is.
(Karnish beatboxing)
- [Arthur] Today, beatboxing lives within,
and beyond its hip hop beginnings.
(beatbox music)
Beatboxing's origin story
is about making do with what you have.
(Napom beatboxing)
And that's why it's become
such an innovative art form.
(Napom beatboxing)
The innovative spirit of beatboxing
is what has kept it
around for over 40 years.
And why it's sure to
live on into the future.
(Napom beatboxing)
- Before you go, I wanna let
you know about fight the power,
how hip hop changed the world.
A new PBS series hosted
by hip hop legend Chuck D,
it's about how hip hop
became a global movement
that spoke truth to power.
Check out the link in
the description below
and let them know Sound Field sent you.
- It's the beatbox house
and you're now watching Sound Field PBS.
(all beatboxing)